hi everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we're going to be
continuing our middle game strategies
and tactics videos i had a lot of
requests in the last video that I need
more middle game strategies and tactics
that that's really helping you guys out
as far as gaining your knowledge in
chess and so as many of you know I try
to make my videos based on
recommendations and requests and so
that's what I'm going to do along with
my normal openings and traps videos I'm
going to try to do more and more with
middle game tactics and strategies that
I think will help improve everyone's
game and today we're going to be
focusing on the f7 square if you've seen
any of my other videos you need to know
that particular for black for white it
would be tf2 squared but for black the
f7 square is a very very vulnerable
square especially at the beginning later
on in the game you're really looking for
different things but in the early and
mid game you're definitely looking at
the f7 square is a huge weakness for
black but I really want to in this video
talk about when you should be attacking
and when you shouldn't be because a lot
of people hear the f7 square is a
weakness so you know every game I play I
just want to go at it and you really
need to understand that when you play
chess especially going into the middle
game a lot of what you're looking for in
the middle game is determined by the
opening that you play so you may have an
opening repertoire that you play that
really does not suit you best to attack
the f7 square or your opponent may be
playing it offense that's really not
going to attack the f7 Square and have
good results it's going to be blocking
that f7 square so that's what what we
are going to be looking at today first
thing you want to notice in the opening
of a game is if you play e4 you're going
to have more opportunities to attack
your opponent's f7 Square then you would
if you play d4 now why is that and
that's simply because when you play e4
your opponent more times than not now
there are many different variations of
chess but a lot of times he's going to
play a move
similar to e5 or he wants to play e5
later on now from here doesn't matter
some players like to play Knight to f3
some players immediately immediately
like to play Bishop to c4 that's not
really one of what I want to focus on
what I do want to focus on is it doesn't
matter where we come out as you can see
this epon for black is not protecting
this f7 Square and from here you're
normally not going to see pawn to d5 you
just don't see that very often you may
see pawn to d6 though if you're playing
the Philidor defense then as you can see
here both of these pawns d6 + e5 neither
of these ponds are defending this pawn
on f7 so now if we were to bring our
Bishop to c4 you can see right away that
this light square Bishop attacking this
f7 Square we're going to have a very
good attack on this however we want to
proceed but if we reverse it and look at
pawn to d4 a lot of times black will
respond with pawn to d5 now as you can
see the big difference here there's
already one pawn here protecting this f7
Square you usually are going to be
attacking the f7 Square with your light
square bishop that's why and a lot of my
videos you may hear that in early game
the light square bishop is more powerful
than the dark square bishop now later on
I have made other videos on you know
which bishops are better but early on
and in the middle game a light square
bishop is more powerful because he can't
attack the f7 square but also keep in
mind a lot of times I open up with e4 so
as you can see here it doesn't really
matter where white continues let's just
continue with f3 it doesn't really
matter a lot of times you may see move
from black similar to pawn to e6 now as
you can see
these may look similar but as far as
attacking the f7 square they're very
very different now we have two pawns
here on d5 and X that are both defending
this f7 pawn so it's going to be much
harder for us to attack this f7 Square
especially with our LightSquared Bishop
so keep in mind that although you always
want to be attacking in my opinion and
especially on the f7 square it really
depends on which opening both of you
play so if you're a d4 player for life
that's completely ok but just keep in
mind in the back of your head that f7
may not be your main focus for the rest
of the game let's take a look at this
example from white as you can see here
both sides have really just started to
bring out some pawns into the game and
white has brought is Bishop to c4 very
common move for white at the same time
you can see the LightSquared Bishop is
attacking the f7 pawn and really for the
rest of the video we're going to be
talking about if the f7 square is a
possibility to attack again we've
already seen that sometimes it's not
right and hopefully you can see in your
own game when it's ok to attack the f7
Square and when it's not but from here
white really wants to continue his
development he really has one move
that's out that's his bishop on c4 so he
may bring his knight to f3 very common
move development move at the same time
bringing his knight to a central square
which can attack and defend the center
but from here it's very important to
notice that we're still attacking this
f7 Square and if blacks not careful then
we're going to run over him in the game
and so these are the things that you
always want to look at because a lot of
times from here a black player will say
you know what
he brought his knight to f3 and what
happens anytime you bring your knight to
f3 well I'm going to bring my Bishop to
g4 because we want to pin this knight
down to this Queen here we can't move
this Knight anywhere else we'll take the
but what black does not see here is that
his f7 square is very weak and we can
bring our Queen to b3 and we're now
attacking this undefended b7 square and
at the same time we're doubly attacking
this square here on f7 so we're going to
win a pawn here and depending on how
black tries to continue we may go up a
lot more in material so as you can see
here since we notice that we were
attacking this f7 squared we were
already looking for black to make a
mistake and once he did then we pounced
on it take a look at this position from
white it's very very important to notice
that even though we're farther along in
the middle game and even though we
haven't attacked this f7 Square and even
though Black has already castled we
still have our LightSquared Bishop on
this a2 square and it's still attacking
this f7 square and it's also pinning
down this pawn to this King here this is
still a very very strong attack and it's
always good to have if there if you see
black has his pawns on d6 + e5 it's
always always important if you can have
a light square bishop along this light
diagonal to always be putting pressure
on this f7 squared because you never
know down the road if you can attack
this square and you can't move and you
can just pin this down to the King and
then you really have a strong attack
from here white has a lot of different
options one of the options that he has
is he can bring his pawn to f4 and
really start to attack as you can see
black it's kind of in a passive state he
has his pawns kind of in a nice little
formation here his bishops aren't very
active and his pieces on the back row
much like ours aren't doing much but we
can open up the game here with pawn to
f4 and if he captures then she
see here we can bring our rook into the
action a truck to f4 and now we have two
attackers against this f7 square at the
same time if we wanted to we could next
bring our queen excuse me - the h5
Square putting another attacker on that
f7 after we do that we can also double
up and bring our other rook to the F
file and this is going to be a very
strong attack but more importantly you
really want to focus that this Bishop on
a2 really allows us to start this attack
it would be almost futile if we just
started throwing our major pieces at
this f7 squared if we didn't have the
support of our bishop on a2 so keep this
in mind even at the very beginning of
the game if you throw your Bishop out
here to c4 and you can't do an attack if
you can have this entire diagonal open
it's still very good even after the
black castles the black King castles
it's still going to be a very strong
attack for you
so this has been the first video there's
going to be a few squares that I did
want to go over on how to attack them
and what you should look for very easy
to know when you should have beat
sacking the f7 square and when you
shouldn't be so when you should be just
looking out for things be looking out
for when you should be attacking what
pieces you should be throwing at them
and just always keep this in the back
your mind so hope you guys enjoyed this
video
a little middlegame tactic for all of
you trying to improve your middle game
and just think of a few more things to
look at while you're playing chess the
more things that you can see in chess
the better you will become as a chess
player so if you haven't already
subscribed please subscribe I'm going to
have a lot more of these videos coming
out in the near future I'll be having a
lot more videos on different squares and
how to attack them but if you haven't
checked out the website be sure and do
that www.hs website calm now we'll see
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching